The wind's blowing
like crazy, but I'm
still going to try and work
on my net a little bit.
I've lost too many
fish by trying
to just pluck them
out of the river
after I get them close to me.
So I'm making my
own that so I won't
have that problem anymore.
Come on!
It's pretty awesome.
I've been working on that
thing for quite a while.
I'm just going to
flex this willow.
I want to bend it
eventually into a circle.
Now I'll take one of
these strands of paracord.
I just got to keep going around.
This country is wearing on me.
Tired of the wind, tired of
the storms, tired of the heat,
and I'm tired of the bugs.
You're wearing on me, Mongolia.
I liked you at first,
bud, and I still like you.
But your attitude is
starting to piss me off.
Vancouver Island was hardcore.
It proved to me that I'm tough.
Not many people get to go as
far as their breaking point.
I was lucky enough
to get there once
and it left a
serious mark on me.
I'm going to take a break here.
[bleep] wind!
[bleep] this place!
[bleep] damn it!
You're either screaming hot,
storming, or [bleep] windy
in a fire season, you [bleep].
[bleep]
Just calm the [bleep] down!
Calm down!
[bleep]
The wind comes from one
direction and the clouds
come from another.
It's an odd place.
The weather has just got
me down a little bit.
Tie a little stop knot.
Try to do a jam knot.
Finish it off with
maybe a half hitch here.
Just like that.
It's done.
I might as well give it a try.
There is a wonderful
bend in my river
that I am calling Steady Eddy.
And I am pulling quite a
few fish out of this area.
It's a sure meat
supply that is making
me feel extremely capable in
my abilities to feed myself.
I got a fish with my net, man!
Oh, and I had the camera
pointed the wrong way.
I got a fish with my net!
I landed him with my net!
Right on!
And that's a big
sucker too, man.
That's a grayling,
just a fat one.
Oh man, I got--
look!
My mission is complete, man!
You know, sometimes
you just need
a good morale boost out here.
Sometimes things just seem
a little overwhelming.
What this journey
had taught me is
to refocus on the small things.
It's amazing how something like
this can change your attitude.
That's a nice
grayling right there.
And I landed it with my net.
I mean, not that there's
anything unusual with that--
I've done it at home with
the same sort of net.
But out here, man--
out here!
Out here, I made this net,
I made this fishing pole.
Out here I did it.